[MUSIC]
Look at this chart.
The figures show percent changes in
maternal mortality over a century long
period, starting in 1784.
And if you focus on AKH Vienna, you'll see
that there was actually a precipitous drop
somewhere in the mid-century.
When we isolate for several factors, we
discover that it probably had something to
do with the discovery of the infectious
properties of medical equipment by Dr.
Ignaz Semmelweis in the mid-century.
This had a major effect
on women everywhere.
[LAUGH]
>> That opening was just awful.
[LAUGH] I started tuning Garett
out probably within the first few
seconds of his speech and
I'm guessing most of you did too.
So, why are openings so important?
Well, it turns out, multiple studies have
shown that we have about ten seconds
to make a good first impression.
That means if our first slide and
our first few sentences out of our
mouth don't capture our audience
attention, we've probably lost them.
Now, is Akash Karia's book How to
Deliver a Great TED Talk, he suggests
three techniques to open your speech
to capture your audience's attention.
Now one technique is to open with a story.
Melody Hobson started her TED talk
with a story about being mistaken for
a server at an event in
which she was a panelist.
Our brains are wired for storytelling.
When we hear a story, we create
a connection between us and the speaker.
It makes that speech that
much more memorable for us.
Another technique is
to begin with a quote.
Elizabeth Pasany started
her Ted talk with a quote,
people do stupid things,
that's what spreads HIV.
The quote was short, relevant, provocative
but not one that's been overused.
And it was impactful, because it was from
an authority on HIV, and it was her words.
A third technique is to start
your talk with a question.
Kelli McGonigal began her TED talk
with questions on how much stress
each person in the audience had
experienced in the past year.
By asking questions and giving people
the time to think of a response,
she engaged her audience and
made her talk more relevant for them.
Now, you don't need to utilize all of
these techniques in your speech, but
incorporating just one of
these elements into your talk
will help you capture your
audience's attention, and
make it more memorable, impactful,
and engaging from the start.
So Garrett,
do you wanna give it another shot?
>> Sure.
I'll try.
Imagine it's 1849 and
you're lying in a hospital bed.
It's actually a very uncomfortable bed,
more like a cart.
And you look to your left and to your
right and you see a row of women who,
like you, have been pregnant for
about nine months, and
you know that today is going to be
a very important day in your life.
A nurse carts you into a smaller room,
it's very cramped, and you smell iodine.
It's a pungent horrible odor.
You hear cries and
screams from a hallway, and
you wonder as the doctor comes
in with giant forceps and
this scary metal device,
is this going to be my last day on earth?
Actually the question
is a very relevant one.
If you're a woman in Vienna in 1849 and
you're expecting a child,
your chance of dying in the next
48 hours is one in five.
That means that if there
are 50 women giving birth,
10 of them will be dead
within the next 48 hours.
But that all changed in the next
year with the discovery
of the infectious properties
of medical equipment.
That sharing medical equipment from
corpses to live women giving birth
caused infection, which killed mothers.
This caused maternal mortality
rates to drop to one in 50.
It was very significant.
But this was all contingent on
the communication skills of
one doctor named Ignaz Semmelweis.
Now I think that we can all agree
that that was a much better opening.
Strong openings allow us to
connect with our audience, and
set the tone for
the rest of our presentation.
Strong closings, however,
are no less important.
Allow me to demonstrate
by finishing the story.
Dr. Semmelweis was an early pioneer
of antiseptic practices in hospitals.
However, he waited ten years
to publish his results.
His results were rejected by the medical
community because they had no
basis in current theory.
He castigated his colleagues,
accusing them of murder.
And they, in turn,
conspired to have him committed
to a mental institution where he died
two weeks later of an infection.
Thank you so much.
It's been a pleasure presenting for
you today.
>> Woah, woah, woah.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Wait a minute.
Dr. Semmelweis' story may have
had an abrupt and bad ending,
but that's no way to end a presentation.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Conclusions are just as
important as introductions.
Oftentimes, we spend so much time
designing and preparing our beginnings but
then we rush through and
forget our endings.
But, the last words out of your mouth
are gonna be what your audience remember
when they walk out of the door, so
your conclusion should contain your
central message, so
it's freshest in your listener's mind.
In his book,
Karia also gives us three techniques we
can use to end presentations effectively.
Can anyone tell me where
this quote is from?
>> Abraham Lincoln?
>> That's right.
This is the last line of
the Gettysburg Address.
In this speech, which is now cited as one
of the most famous speeches in all of
history, Lincoln ended and
left his listeners with a message
of hope as big and bright as
the civil war was dark and painful.
200 years later,
we still remember this message of hope.
The first pass that Karia gives
us to end with hope for a better future.
Second, sell the benefits.
1,000 songs in your pocket.
We all remember this
catchphrase from Steve Jobs,
Apple product launch that we
watched earlier this quarter.
By repeating this line with
1,000 pop songs in your pocket,
over and over, he made sure that
his audience knew the benefit
they would get if they
bought that iPod nano.
And three, call to action.
Ultimately, your conclusion should
have some sort of instructions for
your audience to take away and act on.
Whether that's to learn CPR, to submit
your self-critique on time or to wash your
hands before surgery, your call to action
should be simple and easy to remember.
>> Simple and easy to remember.
That's not exactly how I would
describe the previous slide.
[LAUGH]
When I say the words,
business presentation,
what connotations come to mind?
Boring, difficult to remember,
maybe death by PowerPoint?
We can do much better than that.
By using these simple techniques,
we can create beginnings that
compel our audiences and
endings that leave our audiences
with what we want them to remember.
To me, the moral of the story
of Doctor Semmelweis is that
how we communicate really matters.
He was right, but he failed to persuade.
The way you communicate is important.
Your life may not depend on it, but
your effectiveness as
a business person surely does.
[MUSIC]